I didn’t know you was playing a horse?
I’ve been to drama school.
Hi, my name’s Eamon Farren.
Welcome.
I play Cahir Mawr Dyffryn aep Ceallach.
What?
Witchers.
Hi, I’m Paul Bullion
and I play Lambert.
I’m Yasen Atour and I play Coen.
We’re playing Witchionary!
Wahoo!
Are you going to explain the rules?
Ah ****, the rules.
Basically I will take a card,
try to draw what’s on that card
and if you guys guess right,
you get a point and I get a point.
Are you my inquisitor or executioner?
Are you ready to play Witchionary?
Yes!
Come on,
where’s the excitement,
are you ready
to play Witchionary?
Alright.
Wooo!
Go.
**** yes...
****
Geralt?
Cahir Mawr Dyffryn aep Ceallach?
Sword?
Witcher?
Ah ****, legs!
Sex?
No, he’s an idiot!
Rude.
No, he’s not, he’s good…
Jaskier?
Yes!
He’s an idiot.
You’re amazing,
talent recognises talent.
What is Jaskier doing
in that picture?
He’s playing,
he’s playing his ****,
you know, he’s doing his thing.
Okay.
Window?
Kaer Morhen?
Yes!
I haven’t even been there,
that’s ******.
I’m so good at this,
this is amazing, yes.
Oh come on!
Oh, portal?
Yes!
How did you get that?
I’m amazing.
How long has he got left?
Portal?
No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Kikimora?
Yes!
Did I get it?
Yes, Lamb Chop!
Ciri?
Yep. You got it.
Geralt?
Leshy?
There’s no purple pen…
Yennefer?
Next one, next one, come on.
Don’t waste time baby.
How am I going to do this?
No, you got, you got…
Oh, what the hell is that?
Leshy?
Oh! Basilisk?
It’s Striga.
Oh it’s a mouth. Thank god.
But your drawing is good though,
it looks like a gingerbread man.
Thanks.
He’s doing, he’s trying to do me over,
he doesn’t want me to win.
Why would I-
I guessed all the others!
Good old Lamb Chop.
Go.
Just draw man, draw!
Henry...
Yep.
Geralt.
How did you get Henry out of that?
Henry has some biceps on him.
You’ve got an advantage,
I can’t see…
There we go.
Don’t be bitter, be better.
Ciri?
Yennefer?
No, there’s a hole in the middle…
Testicle?
Boobs?
Babies? Pregnancy? Law of surprise?
Fuck.
Ow! What’s going on?
Oh no.
What Henry again,
more muscles?
Vesemir?
Yes!
Come on, Yas!
How did you get that?
Mate you did really well.
Except the pregnancy got
a little… iffy
Testicles?
Boobs?
I'd love to hear the scores.
I’m graceful.
I’m graceful in defeat and victory.
Anyway, congratulations.
Hats off, hats off to you though,
you were very clever in
how you were drawing…
Love you.
Bye.